I like your outfit thank you very much
yeah it's looking sharp thank you I
tried the beard game yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know got a little
something you know that's what happens
when you're on Hiatus I who care I love
I own a ranch I love the Mountain Man
look it looks cool I love the beer so
you are just in Dubai I have to show
everybody this you're with Shaq Steve
Harvey and Ray Lewis what were you doing
there oh wow what were we were it's
quite a crew yeah those are my Omega
sci-fi brothers too so we were there for
uh for the F1 and Steve Harvey's golf
tournament for charity oh that's cool
yeah well true or false
um I love your beard game but I did hear
that when you were on Law and Order
um you were asked to get rid of it
because Dick Wolf's wife didn't like it
that's the word on the street
my my my first uh my first student loan
order back in 2008-2009 I came with a
beard not as full as this but I came
with a beard we did a full season and
then uh our our second my second season
on the show got a call into dick Wolf's
office I thought I was in trouble and
they were like yeah uh Jeremy Sisto and
I both had beards and we thought we were
both getting fired because we both got
called into the office oh no and
basically it was like you guys need to
shave tomorrow
and uh they worked into the script and
we had to shave our beards oh my gosh
yeah she is a
she is it does sometimes go the other
way
you've traveled with other celebrities
as well so didn't you go to the Bahamas
with Michael Jordan you hang out with
somebody I mean you know I have a great
I have an Eclectic group of friends that
I hang out with no one go
with Michael Jordan dude I do yeah of
course yeah well is he competitive
because he's you know very competitive
uh he's competitive at everything do you
beat him at anything uh that's gotta
feel you know what I'd like to preserve
my friendship
which means you do so uh I I have twice
in my life
yeah that felt good no it didn't I would
have called everyone we I I and I did I
did but this was you this was years of
MJ I'm sorry I didn't bring this up they
just be bringing this stuff I totally
wanted to know um no we played golf
um uh back in uh the Bahamas uh years
ago and he gave me my Strokes he's a
much better player than I am so he gave
me my strokes but I actually beat him
that day without The Strokes wow yeah
that felt good it did and you know it
wasn't real big money but it was enough
money everyone like 900 and he bought
the money up and threw it at my face
and told me I'm never getting Strokes
again and ever since sin he's never
given me my Strokes I know
MJ at anything I know that's why I would
make a shirt yeah and wear it love you
MJ keep your shoes coming keep your
shoes coming
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]